a gente é natal o tanto que eu tô
vermelho o nariz para ser um pimentão
ontem estava aonde foi natal né
de novo é natal todo o campeonato graças
a deus é todo o campeonato da liga pra
mim já tá é sempre uma época muito boa é
que a gente se reúne com a família ontem
muitas datas assim que dá para reunir a
família mas acho que é onde que reúne
todo mundo junto de uma vez só é o natal
e vocês sabem que quando tá todo mundo e
junto de uma vez só não sobra muito
espaço pra todo mundo e é nesse momento
que a gente tem que mostrar toda a nossa
solidariedade natalina e da nossa cama
nossa quarta o nosso ninho na sua vida
os parentes que vem de longe dormi até
curitiba a gente leva um colchão
inflável fica se gabando que tem um
colchão inflável é bom e leva todo lugar
seguido da época achei que ela não
quarta enchente
achei que eu pegue a rede a minha vez
que há pouca chance não é o só
perdedores é bom a all por mais que seja
muito boato é muita gente é bom natal
[ __ ] mal é todo mundo se reúnem a cada
dia trará comida gostosa avião atingir
com frango assado teria lhe recheada aí
vem a tia com feijão tropeiro em outra
tia com arroz zinho aquele que o milho
verde bom asiático pele uai eu tô aqui
com a farofa por todo mundo fazendo a
coisa vai ficando para comer natal
prosseguem com a farofa e depois se
aquela tipo chester joão gigante e do
que o chester chefe é o que me dizem que
é o chefe eu tenho uma teoria
chester a gente não queria ele a gente
planta no seu tempo pensando que um dia
eu vou encontrar o homem mais rico do
mundo vou falar cara de boa como é que
tu consegue ganhar tanto dinheiro e vai
olhar pra mim vai falar meu filho revela
o segredo nem cá a gente chega na
fazenda dela que lhe abre a porteira lá
a plantação gigante de cheste olha os
pés de manga gigante só que em vez de
mandar temos chefe de equipe durango
agora já começar bb espera na hora da
ceia a ser menor tempo que fica pelos
sete horas da noite e dia o cara tá lá
saber que a promessa da galaxu comemora
é o que é a páscoa é a de lançar um mas
não é o caso da cunha toma água estava
tirando o carro
a faixa e bicho aguentou vontade de
conhecer oito horas da noite ou com fome
ou esperar passei a noite não era ficar
conversando há um ano eu já dei um
pouquinho eu tive lá chega a hora da
ceia agora começa a descer se abraçava
da shan para entrar sim da bebida típica
começa a oração para poder comer bem e
eu informei o da redução do vinho na
ação durará tanto a pessoa era um menino
mas dantes nascer para exploração é uma
hora e começa a comer todo mundo feliz é
bom por isso a gente é bom que todo
mundo cansando todo mundo feliz é a
capas e agora vai ter me todo mundo
dormindo de boa só tem uma pessoa no
estado isso
depois ela vai embora no outro dia ruim
é isso depois ela vai embora
a gente fica lá sozinho e cheia de louça
palavra eu juro a vocês que eu tiver um
caso que eu vou fazer não sei lá na hora
que todo mundo ter dado como eu já vou
dizer quem com meu lar seu prato senão o
outro não ver de novo a fim de ano é
assim o quarto onde a família mesmo que
seja uma vez um ano é uma vez que você
está ali sinceramente você está ali com
sua família já possui curtir um pouco
tabu mas se acontecer qualquer tipo de
coisa é um momento de ficar lento eu
quero que você come aqui em baixo o que
de mais engraçado já aconteceu em um
final de ano o que de mais estressante
também já aconteceu no final de ano
comenta em baixo e sabia que aquele
jovem ajuda
pra [ __ ] é a primeira vez que assisti
o vídeo meu clique em escrever toda vez
que alguém você vai saber
achei de vídeo e pelo canal se quiser
assistir outros e também e aquele jovem
e fortalece a amizade em ajuda a gente a
continuar fazendo o trabalho
e outra coisa enquanto xandão joinha o
cara tá lá feliz natal pra você e até
sábado no próximo vídeo na web um bom no
fim